here we go again another day
another police officer shooting a
violent criminal
seems like you can't turn on the news
anymore without seeing these sorts of
stories
enough is enough it is long past time
in this country that we had a national
conversation
about the discriminatory practice in
many police departments
to target people who are committing
crimes that is discrimination
we will have that conversation the libs
are defending the
stabbing of children
they are they are doing that to own the
conservatives
or to own the cops or to own the white
people or i don't know they're just
doing it to push their narrative
but they are actually now in the
position of defending
teenage girls stabbing other teenage
girls
just so that a cop won't intervene just
so they can't give the cop credit for
what he did right
you've probably heard about this story
by now if you haven't
a columbus police officer shot 16 year
old
makia bryant this now that the derek
chauvin trial is over the left needs
some new case to focus on to pretend
that the country's really racist and
terrible
and black people are always being
attacked and white people are the devil
so they're focusing on this case poor
little sixteen-year-old makia bryant cut
down in her prime
by a racist vicious cop except for this
very inconvenient fact that we only know
about because of body camera footage
which was that as when the cop
shot makia bryant she was inches away
from stabbing another girl
we've got the footage cop gets out of
his car
walks up there's some kind of
altercation going on
okay someone gets knocked to the ground
and now a girl there it is girl gets
shot
the girl gets shot and she is
inches away from stabbing with a steak
knife
another young girl it all
it all kind of goes into this melee when
this first person on the side goes down
the cop is turned
facing the person who goes down cop
pulls out his
his gun you got you've got the footage
right there this girl makia bryant
is wielding a giant knife a
pull wraps it around on the side is
about to plunge it down
into this other girl is inches away from
it and then the cop
rightly shoots the attacker
that is the only thing that he could do
while still doing his job in pursuing
justice
a just society would give this cop a
medal
a just society would give this cop an
award
he saved a girl's life and shot a
knife-wielding attacker
our society is going to try to destroy
him he's going to try to put him in
prison is going to try to ruin his
family
he's going to call him a racist because
he shot one black girl to save another
black girl who was about to be stabbed
by the first black girl but that makes
him a racist somehow
that's what's going to happen here some
people want to
they want to say look can't we just all
get along can we just have it both ways
can't look maybe he shouldn't have done
that but you know look i guess the girl
had a knife but you know maybe he should
it's it's just a really sad thing
it's a tragedy we'll get to the tragedy
in a second because we have to get
through some of the
stupid questions surrounding this first
i kid you not
there is the suggestion on the left that
the officer
should have not shot shot the victim or
shot the perpetrator rather
shot to kill he should have just shot
her in the ankle or something
shot her in the wrist shut her in shut
the gun right out of her hand
this was a question posed to the police
chief yesterday
one of the big questions that has been
asked primarily on social media and it
may seem like a silly question that like
shouldn't people already know but this
is a legitimate question that a lot of
people are asking
is can an officer
shoot the leg can they shoot somewhere
that would not result in a fatal move
right so a lot of people have said
couldn't have just shot her in the leg
so she throbbed could he have shot her
in the arm something like that
right you know okay we got to pause it
right there before we get to his answer
because he this cop is pretty diplomatic
here and but i will not be diplomatic
this is an extremely dumb question
basically what this reporter is asking
and look i'm not even knocking on the
reporter the reporter is just channeling
what a lot of very
stupid ignorant people on the internet
are saying he's basically asking
hey couldn't couldn't the cop have shot
the knife out of the girl's hand
without harming her like clint eastwood
and the good the bad and the ugly
couldn't the cop have had you know when
he heard that harmonica come on
couldn't he have just whipped out his
gun shot the knife out
and then you know the girl she would
have looked really startled like the
like the other guy in the good the bad
and the ugly and then but then they all
kind of would have laughed about it no
one would have gotten hurt
couldn't that come on i saw it i saw it
in the movies that's the quest no that's
not
i won't i won't even explain why you
can't do that i will allow
the expert the cop to explain why that
is not such a great idea
one of the uh the difficult things with
that is um when you're trying
we we don't train to shoot the leg
because that's a small target
we train to shoot center mass what is
available to stop that threat
there was a threat going on a deadly
force threat that was going on so the
officer is trained to
shoot center mass the largest part part
of a body
that is available to them when you try
to start shooting legs or arms
rounds miss and then they continue on
and there are people behind that
that could be in danger that are not
committing anything
so we try and minimize any danger to
anyone else
if we have to use our firearm when you
pull out a firearm
in real life that is not a video game
when you pull out you're not playing
around it's not
here's a warning someone i actually saw
someone say on twitter
why couldn't he fire a warning shot into
the air like he's a mexican gangster
oh you know because i don't know if
you're aware of this
bullets when they go up
because of gravity they come back down
and if you're just shooting into the air
when they come back down it might not
work out too well for you or for an
innocent bystander why couldn't he just
shot her in the leg one
she's moving like crazy two actually i'm
sorry the first consideration here is
she's got a knife inches from this
girl's body
she's got a knife coming down very
quickly in this girl's body so shooting
her in the leg probably not a smart idea
even if it did work
second leg very very small
area moving very rapidly you've got lots
of people around you don't need bullets
spraying everywhere
when you pull out a weapon and you shoot
that weapon at somebody
you are shooting to kill that person
that's just the way it works
that's what guns do that's what guns are
for
and by the way cops have guns for a
reason cops have guns
to stop bad guys from doing bad things
like this girl who was trying to stab
and by the way when you're stabbing
you're not you're not just playing games
either
when you pull a knife out and you stab
somebody you are trying to kill that
person
and this cop saved that girl from
getting killed by that other girl
that's a good thing wait a second way
down not so fast
pull your hands away from the keyboard
or from your screen
you've got to smash that button you got
to
subscribe you got to like you've got to
make sure that you
get all of the videos that are coming up
because youtube
doesn't necessarily love our content
they don't always want to promote it so
make sure
that you are there for all the latest
videos
see you next time